Miranda Divine as always is on it she's
with the New York Post helped break the
hunter Biden laptop story in the first
place joins us tonight Miranda thanks so
much for coming on this doesn't seem
like partisan Rock throwing this seems
like an actual story to me is it
yes and look I think this might be the
Breakthrough story uh because really the
cover-up of Biden corruption is like
Watergate now bigger than the original
story uh it involves the FBI the CIA now
you're seeing this um quite honest uh
upright
um completely non-partisan career IRS
criminal investigator who has a lot of
big scalps under his belt and is just
treating the hunter Biden story like he
did any other case is furious he's been
stymied he sees that there's been
political interference and obstruction
in the case and then I think what really
set him off and made him goja the
Inspector General of the Department of
Justice and turned into a protected
whistleblower was seeing a month ago
Merrick Garland appear at an oversight
hearing and give very misleading
testimony you know he was asked
specifically by Chuck Grassley
is the U.S attorney in Delaware able to
bring charges in California and in
Washington DC these are the two
jurisdictions where Hunter Biden
lived and should have paid taxes and
Merrick Garland assured Grassley oh yes
David why says every Authority in power
that he needs and I'm backing him up and
this is all very independent that is
just the opposite of the truth and
really if Merrick Garland doesn't know
that he's not doing his job properly
if Merrick Garland can be shown to have
lied under oath to the Congress I mean
the Attorney General of the United
States can't commit crimes I mean by
definition that's got to be the end of
him as our attorney general I would
think
well it would be if you could have
approved it but all of these people are
clever they have plausible deniability
they have layer upon layer in which they
can pretend that they don't know what's
happened that's what Joe Biden's entire
business model is all about his
relatives go and get the bribes and he
pretends he doesn't know about it
that's such a smart point
Irvine thank you so much for that
summary tonight we'll be talking again I
hope
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight